а
надягайте що таку сталін скоро донську
архітектуру міністерство святих самі
системі схожа пуччиною оветти twitter
сміт проноситься звичаєм новий міністр
сьогодні і просто розплутаємо в кабінеті
шкоди
добрий та й сир та vita його знову ніби в
тему кабінеті на та паші я вітаю важливих
наручники міну
яку міду і на батьківщині джем і потрібний був
ту ж дугу бо гра чутки ладу канада
це була конференція вчителів
про та водою агрос
навчання дітей через компетентні
петлі і темою і тисячі кого
де ти хлопчик або самий, щоб до
потрібне мужики
i might на вчати ся в такий спосіб шуб
школа була дружніша і дати їй дитину і
ось на темп рацію і віч канаті вже
продовжу 20 руки на привал та шкода ми
моєму душі за перетасованою з місця
святі кріпиш годину нехай і але додаю
будь-якої інформації інформацію інформацію та
ми не йшли ж на мою думку до
конкретні щури замість квіти калли
гітів же не може саків ну ти всі три
Адже інформації творить і як результат
війни перемонтажу не ласкання вікна туди
їжу зі мною і яскравість його почту на вигляд
ж переорієнтація за з колишніми кейками
стис місця на формування ключових
компетентностей аки по три дні для
сучасна і людей на 25 означають ті ключі
рггу правити не країни світу
засіки краю на європейську спілку видих
та діалог про такі ключові
компетентності maemo ти випускник після
з дуба тебе повна загальна та середнього
квіти і е п relic так їх компетентностей
починай черговий новий 2 іноземний
мама там чудово грамот ниць природний
що грамотність коли мене роботи в
команді так вже фінансово грамотний
ipad наступник двох культур на комп і
компетентність
я до 100 суеца вашого критичного
мислення і в міні суртурі а то інформацію
і викури 100 висновок і для вас рішення
жаку в їхніх проблем
тис партнери формована нас правде ту
ж складно тому що wanna коротко
відривала які наскільки руки у тебе від
реформа
у вас заплановано збиток не гра старт
адже на цій конференції вас вона я
болгарію свій із правої і ось тут ми
хочемо показати цю концепцію те що
треба знати і процедури форму в 4-му
бочкам робота та всім дітям топ те що
різанини
групи знаєш ліфті та реформі відповіді
на око не харчування у церкви з буди і ми
роздоріжжя йому переліт наших стандартів
про святих ми відразу так серйозно грама я
бачу тут у вас дати опік тіла куб м і
мишачий до кінця вигляд кольору волосся
медаль на рамо труша ідея була пилюка
лежав у що psy хто захоче ми не
приведуть і ми ви вирішили щоб ти був у
швидкість судити це та зруби ти так що
подарунки мало гуппи книжка to the van
der valk не треба кричати а обличчі малому
різні гарніри дівчинки аудиторії цьому
що ми ланцюга питав з функції дарини
жовдак на ту тему тебе фундація
займається живленням сбу рук ножем для
бібліотек сільських шкіл показую ось
напасти ми ви вирішили таким чином до
допомога бібліотекам сільських шкіл
колумбійський університет ви були там
поважав поневірятися ми пошарив пульт аж і
так до міста під я типу ревниво ти
підходи там cool убити мене отримаєш
цьому аркей польша нам би ще польщі і
так тому що ви на iq раз прийшла цар
порожній
радянську пострадянську трансформацію
не нехай охолонула ніби я gras у той час у
щоку лимон через провалюй свою реформу
implement вали тури форму і пройшло 10
руки
вид моменту початку імплементації
реформи і що його неможливо пухнасті у
нас зустрічі з поляком маяки bull та ікра
слизьким реформатором вибач за крима
ями школа папірцями та рай знайди
жуковської ірина dish готське та
називалася серцем польська іра формула
святим вона була державним стократ арам
міністерстві про почти польші них було
ж біль та сну
реформа усвяти б ви не поділили школи
на шлях від кави україні гімназії україни
і лице його краями і боготу пузатий їх
струмками інше як ми можемо у чіпі з його
поляки е так вже й полки
регіоні шкір можемо у чому ми можемо
покращити з наших полицях щоб їх не
допускати червона можна сказати що система
свино випадково національно притому вона
ось я наведу маленький приклад ми
дуже багато під час протесту пара вигляд
адже ходу ти класно-урочної системи
нальчани так і і різьблені внучки
форма ти навчання алея для частин на
українського та українського суддівства для
їх зрозуміло так наша школа займається
відзначаємо з чим по три але думи по ви не
підпишете методи
прусова ти надходила ми підлога небудь fp
нами штани ми валу 9 вчить або що ланцюг
правильно в плані на українську так
бандитки на відтінок світліший на і
прекрасніше і зняв її старій буряк інші
віці тут у і силища зачистивши kycok
міністрів та принесло свої школи я прийшла
цар кабінет на менти смоли чи будемо
університеті за галєїв cc гуляли і
усвідомлюються такі канцелярські для мене
важлива ваша видавився хочеться їхніх дітей
отця відслужив ми всі проц і ви йому
за рідних ось карта як атакувати вашу
ідею про кравців skill to cause мистецтво
Централізацію ці школи мотиви це
скажемо там
одна школа на кілька сил і куди будуть
звозити дітей автобусами
саме ідея тут на я завзято школа і
дається які знову свято для кожної
української та дитинки як і щілина
встановити у дозах благополучних районах
нічого іншала не вигадала я касетах і
рубає і упор не kusabi школи їх називають
хопс кус але хто там та й нормальніший
умова навчання раз витку бачив
методології qualify for any в 4
тому що скажете бидло скачений з краще
нам для дітей не особливо його старших
класах 1 в 4 колишня д кілька предмета і
англійської та фізкультури та наприклад
фізику вчи історію потім мета
старшокласники хмара сонячними
затримувати синього не я просто на мої
шанси для ременя інженер спитаю класно
коміки в чіпсах жіноча людина може
бути еталоном у цій нас сьогодні за 100
тис таке гід із села в 10 разів майк
менше шанс із пласта успішно сонячне
тест його немає і натискаємо ок він виявляти
у хлопців школи колег можна буде
фізично кубачі
супер за сив і з'являється в ж і нас
ж довозять дітей а ліза різних дуже
інтенсифікації процес і ж tell уроку
гаранта - ташкін ланцюга потрібен куш там
та утримання бюджету 600 у червні у наші
дні автобусі до державного бюджету 200
мільйонів на пофарбування бази з їх скіл
органи місцели та влади моїх до дати
свою половину і вид у видно а нові
тайти школи
звучали стоїмо не дуже багато проблемної
беша проблемою вікна мене зайчик у мене
душа болить серце cf4 які і зустрічає
роботу на приклад у нирки бобрик коли
дзвеніли о 1 годині через таку
модернізацію мразей 6004 і для них створ
або вид поведінки програм та пити ринку
і ось зараз для нас важливо його
і цілі клік їжа готова ти всі чоловіки в
стеку може мотати і в 4
не тільки там одноразову виплату я до
ним гаранту та c
трудовим кодексом а також за розуміти
що може зрубує і центри зайнятості
може бути ікон крил
радіальні бути навіть на їжу ті з і
піти
димом і створили там ще під кумом проти
кабінет давати різні види що це
момент ратифікації
асоціації з європейським союзом одну годину
твоєї ратифікації кабула в нас
парламенті не в європейському зразкові
терміни обірвали зав'язок і з би у нас
правді дуже гірший момент уми шоколад і
розуміючих утягну заплатив і це лише їх
за раз і цивілізовану рафікову ти в
угоду про асоціацію з його душею
дозатори 155 народних депутатів
тут покажи ось ви це п'єте як циклу
лосяша частка вас за волоссям вона сметанку
на єву чому не було що десять разів на
першому курси я говорила своїм бути
канікули вчитуватимуся в тому, що я
свої трофеї батьківщини у потрійному покоління
я тобі роботу знає душа добра ім'я
busy in титус чат або вали мама
бочку б ви кладу чимось у те я говорила
своїй мамі я потреби бачила маму за такими
попитом і сашенці іванів язик ви на
викладаючи фізика та образ творчих місць
хвилі атака ту ж річку стороні я
казала та nicoline та будучи то нам та я
хотіла ніби біохіміком червона частка робот
своє
у мене народився трохи. і я прийшла
на групу продовженого дня до школи та
кіз знаходилася опублікує колеса кинджала
і я почала проти то тут ми я відразу
милий шосе
якщо твої справи то я була і в чиїсь
нам біології і шлях їм довелося взута і
заступником директора та директором школи
і я теж добрий спробують і момент
червовий клею була директором школи і в
маленький чонко випускниця дуже гарно
який же на той момент писав вона
статті ви наступала на журналістику
і
ступила думу ще мамі говорив і наметі
підданий хабар і я їх директор школи але
було на звучання біля бурого на що тесту ми
робом у путіна з правдина рейтингу
повернете спеціальності на чегет, а це
адже був нудний і моїх право бути говорячи
прорив придушити і овочі висвітлять іди і
а система за неї заражають і знову
реформи та ось бачите застосована
система можна ось вона ставить сотки валу
при подачі вони право так ви виправив я
за зустрічаю людей ки кожним цим я куя
миші все-таки за нього було удачі вам
було моє харчування як обороти корупцію в
стані середню
там пішов і тіло подарунки в 4-му
проплачені звичайним столом і освітленням.
і але я таки in the city абсурд не
розрахував цьому 4 кор у мене немає рогові
комп'ютер мета живлення прозорою та
гидко sti факт полежав там вже і наша
система светрах у його недофінансованому
тільки від бюджету виділяти п'ятисотці ВВП
бо на меблі за маму самого скінами
77 при на шов читали виду частина ось тут
не а тепер давайте піднімемося на
соціальний статус вчителя сьогодні має
позову зарубати на плато в 4
маргіналізованою і ту професію знайдуть
краще
сьогодні важливі у завданні все-таки
піднімає і соціальний статус вчителя та
всю професію наводить і молодих таланів
цих людей
клімта васу space твій а хто до моєї
пустуватий освоюваних їжу школи що
означає, що в школі я пісень і
сумлінний гривні на краще цієї мови
купити міні комп'ютер тому що інакше я
буду погано ставите сюди ваших дітей
вогонь і здається all i'm a та c на уазі
і бачка і на прикладній суть жорсткіша і на
катує with nasty проти гаїв agip сема
і будьте абсолютно ганьба їм, наприклад ми
в законі просвітова тема законопроекту
кі зарості верховній раді
за клани положення що всі кішки кен
відходять
у шкіл вбито держави вигляд ні з цього ви
бюджету а так і вид батька герда
пружини в низькому німецьких людей
організацій моїх ніби опубліковані на
сайті школи я думаю що так up
зорі змажемо моїй агрос за краще ти і
бочки та на ціна key
давай то від ви так залипли все борошно. а
тут же hd blue саша гори війни за спиною
найкращих задка протоки ска область we
взаємно україна
суха душелюб коханої вона народилася і
альваро свого вірного дну хувер ну і
знає імені гурін відпочивають як такі
коли ти хочеш на що з про рпц
для мене це українські гори так для мене
це так вже
але я шоху читаєте авів ікона мети копія
українську та ікони яко зроблено стали
пивного бару core і 17 стільці тему
одігітрія я віруючі люди на алла мвц
крем табу приклад чудово українського
мистецтва ви нам і маяка є фінансові
велике цінності at allure ви на пов'язано
з моєю руди ною батькові чулося orgy with
пупера його міністра
елена розуміє я не знімаю був у них
загинув мій плакат буф у комітеті
випробувань наука її почту верховної ради
знаєте моя у сови 100 проблема калію
почала ніби на корінних посадок з
проблема говорити про неї за раз і їжу ж
чітко система заїкою ти можеш звірі ти
трубиш правильно чани prime чорт ctr за
що люди вину
aus кути впав його новинок за владним
тому я мій приклад навіть
близьких людей ми близько доторкнутися і q і
я бджоли салдана кендра цска і людина в
осаці троцький та річки вже мавіші при 10
руки вінкл різьблення в десантних у неї
тиснемо виріжемо піт і добровольцям туніку
лиж і сам путча струм even зазирнувши і
заклався двоє гіту які не пам'ятаю
літні ось cool її думаю проти людей
киру голити вибір крутих хто заглянувши
колимі трава казок і не
і дуже жорсткого за раз я не маю їм
проблем
це важливого фотографія там і шивана
зрубаного дні школі пити слов'янською
ника була зовсім розстріляна тя школами
сама андрей григорович пишний я каякер
я вже з банком я до ванги будинку взявши на
себе патрон від видно фланець і їй
адже школи в слов'янську ж буду вали
так вже там ще від банку не знаю взагалі
сара та не там займалася out у 4-ох ним
дуже і
процесі в Україні яскравість стала не до
дітей до історії України 10
правильні складні харчування проти
конкретну школу я хто каже це там я
назву чай але такі пасіонарні
директор школи і я дуже одягається
школа буду функцію на ватою функціоналу
ти добрий і алли проблема при до ви сказали
в носі суеца всієї України ми моєму і про
і ви по виїмці такий яка супер цьому за
раз теж важливі його відразу не тануть
роботу йому дали з українською 4 майк but i
інвестиції вчителя алей та в ньому в
4 але привели до та шкода у сьогоднішній
ситуації в Україні ми не можемо моду
дзвонить sub1 момент але піднято зарплату
всім вчителям ми по ньому ти висновок інший
крадіжок теплого не пройшла добровільну
сертифікацію ключів черепа на і
мають право претендувати на біржу
зарплата доступний вид буде присвячений
розробити таку і сертифікацію ми
тут багату outed у вас вчать і я відразу
звернула мало того, щоб відразу
дрібнитися про дванадцяткову систему
свити
чому така карта каші добре почалася
може тому, що люди думають що нашим
дітям треба будуть сидить ще один риф
тінейджери школі всій школі я знаю
гірше дітей даному чай нафти школі та
ккд куди знаєш що я здоров'я дітей та
так і 12 рік нікому непотрібний у тому
числи ми них міністр цирку імплементації
б усі задаються харчуванням колегу dc та
дванадцятий рік від кого, бо 12
рік з йдуть від кави ви дотки української
бюджету
я йшов і ось
у нього за чіткою школу з першого класу
за провалюємо реформу зв 17 19 руку
ми його 3 ми йому дадуть кого ерик 12 рік
школи 29 тридцятому початковому ротик
коли означає хитатися і 12 ерік додати
з 2017 не не
алея все б у нас був убив фінансово
не це я
ієна про нас правді при сильних швах чого
за проведення реформи вона для тіла
трава та наречену вати і в принципі можна
було б за право чого ти з 5 класу
результаті ми 12 рикманоф 25 двадцять
шостому уроці в результаті проти ти що всі
ці 12 роки скільки бог наказав і повік
і де наказів тому що можна
цін можна рубати і рятуйте і міністра та
випадково що це дуже важливо лідерська
позиція деви ви кабель на вигляд не якщо а
і на плечі али я думаю що чистий ну і
цілей реформи команди і жолобиться
реформи та душові крапельки з людом то в
таких будуть розроблені дві
стандартного св якихось створі в
цієї navi підручник і
ваша бібліотека тут моя бібліотека і тут
я дуже багато джеррі для мене ось
напружуватися і дуальне на вч вони
офіційно технічніше висвітливши нас заразу
живота проблем з офіційно технічні
святий мій заклик ми сконцентрувалися
тітенькій на школі алиш спектр харчування
значить знайшов третяки лозунги, що летять
навчили так то головний ївши ти
лице їжу ж важливо його для розуміння що
ми можемо сьогодні за пробку ну вати і
учнів відповідь українська в 4 я обожаю
для нас наступ і в годину голими з вини
супроводіть один базовий документ у
тиват їм жити а саме ебут і на
затверджено та нормативно-правовим актам c
та точний кодекс 4
як засмучена так можна і такте називати
али в читай читай не може тут його
анти тримаючи миску агітацію в 4 травня як
промо туром конституції України
чотирма з якогось 7 і мід ес по
когось утримує мною нову в 4 травня в
хобот і по го року своєї ідентичності та
4 травня у пана ти їдеш людей і тепер
повинен став цієї зі сплаву виїду шкірну
усу б врятувати її такі універсальні
промови які притому вони високому імені в 4
ви ж я кого я обманюю цирозу
глав мід їх